a Mississippi soldier sharing an
emotional story that illustrates the
sacrifices our service members may
specialist Brooks Lindsay was in Texas
preparing to deploy overseas when his
pregnant wife went into labor with their
first child he got permission to fly
home but when his flight was delayed he
used technology to join the excitement
in the delivery room
Omar Villafranca is outside River Oaks
Hospital in Flowood Mississippi that's
just outside Jackson Omar good morning
good morning baby millie was making her
grand entrance two weeks early at this
hospital while her father was more than
1,000 miles away in El Paso but this
military dad was not gonna miss this
special moment I was freaked out that
Brooks Lindsey was emotional as he
rushed home to Mississippi from El Paso
Texas for the birth of his first child I
get to Dallas just fine and then find my
next gate and find out that the flight
is going to be delayed and at that point
Haley was starting to push so his mom
facetimed him from the delivery room and
Brooks had no choice but to sit on the
floor of DFW Airport and witnessed the
birth I was talking to Haley talking to
my mom watching Millie be born it was it
was all pretty pretty intense push push
push push push you got it you got it
here she comes and then boom she popped
out fellow passenger Tracey Dover
captured the moment I'm thinking oh my
gosh he's watching his baby be born on
the phone and it was the most
gut-wrenching heartbreaking thing I'd
ever seen once his baby girl was born
Brooks wasn't the only one celebrating
when we heard the baby cry then just
just that whole section that was heading
the Mississippi just started cheering
two hours later Brooks made it to the
hospital to hold his newborn daughter
Millie we're so happy he could make it
home I'm very thankful I would have
never had guessed that it was gonna turn
into all this because all I wanted to do
just make it home and see my baby girl
be born baby Milly and mom are back home
while specialist Lindsay is getting
ready to be deployed to Kuwait but he's
looking on the bright side had that
flight actually been on time he would
have missed everything because he would
have been up in the air
Gail see there's a silver lining Thank
You Omar Villafranca don't we just love
his expressions while he's watching baby
milligan here and I love my baby Milly
yes and that we're all sort of in on it
too we're glad you're here the world
thanks again Omar that was great